[Music]
[Music]
this is where it happens with a smile a
skillful touch a thoughtful look the
morning rush an evening stroll out in
the cold but always warm
we are the frontline hear us see how we
work together
with Chromebooks in our hands
we'll be faster more connected and
better informed
we'll keep going the distance
[Music]
and we'll always have your back
because we are the frontline
hello and welcome to cloud on-air live
webinars from Google cloud we're hosting
webinars daily my name is Laura Jones
and I'm from the chrome Enterprise team
and today we'll be talking about how to
turn your frontline workers into cloud
workers you can ask questions anytime on
the platform and we have Googlers on
standby to answer them let's get started
so first you might be wondering well
what's a cloud worker so let's start out
there now it's fair to say that the
cloud has fundamentally changed the way
that many of us interact with technology
in our personal lives we're used to a
world where at a click of the button I
can stream music or movies to any device
that I want I can order up a car to meet
me exactly where I am and take me
exactly where I'm going it's technology
that works instantly that's easy to use
that's seamless across all of my devices
and all of this interaction with cloud
technology and our personal lives has
raised the expectations for the way that
technology should work at work and
there's many employees today that are
using cloud technology to do the vast
majority of their work and they're
preferring that as well and we call
these workers cloud workers and they
make up today about 25% of the employee
population but we think that that's just
going to grow over time
these cloud workers value speed
convenience collaboration and fluidity
of work they want to be able to work
wherever whenever they like now when you
think about a cloud worker you might
think ok I know who these people are
they work in technology they're probably
in marketing but the fact is that cloud
workers span beyond traditional role
segments it's not about where you work
but about how you work and we think that
one segment of the workforce that could
benefit the most from cloud technology
and perhaps could be the easy
to move to cloud technology our
frontline workers so let's talk about
what we mean when we say frontline
workers these are the workers that are
building the products that people
customers interact with they're the
people in front of customers who are
impacting the brand every single day and
they're often deathless their cashiers
nurses call center agents people on the
manufacturing line 80% of the global
workforce is deathless and many of these
deathless workers are frontline workers
front line workers build up of wealth of
knowledge from the routine and essential
services that they provide every day and
this is knowledge that is critical for
headquarters for a brand to be able to
tap into they're the backbone of the
company and they're the face of the
company whether they're building the
product or directly in front of
customers frontline workers have a
direct impact on the customer experience
which impacts the bottom line to think
about the last time you had an
interaction with a brand
you were probably interacting with a
frontline worker you were at a
restaurant and had great service you
were speaking to a call center agent and
had maybe bad service how did that
impact the way that you thought about
that brand the reality is that it
probably had a lot more impact of the
advertisements that we see every day and
this brand interaction is extremely
important to the business
according to HP our customers who have
positive experiences spend one hundred
and forty percent more with the brand
than those who don't
but even though they have this outsized
impact frontline workers are often left
behind and their full potential remains
largely untapped because of it according
to another HP our survey only 12% of
leaders believe their organizations
invest sufficiently enough and the
frontline managers were the people
training
making sure that the frontline workers
that the servers that the call center
agents are able to do their jobs well
and frontline workers who have to deal
with a lot of communication don't feel
like they have the tools to be able to
manage that communication and even more
75% of frontline workers feel their
employers aren't telling them enough
about the changes in policies and goals
so think about that if these are the
people that are meant to represent your
brand and they don't know enough about
what's going on at the company and what
the company's mission is they can't do
their jobs as effectively as they should
be able to be we've also seen that
they're being left behind Tech by
technology we did a survey at Google
where we asked information workers and
frontline workers whether the technology
in their workplace has changed over the
past five years and what we found is
that information workers 70 percent of
them said yes and you know I think
that's that's pretty standard but when
we ask frontline workers only 50 percent
of them said yes I think about how much
technology has changed over the past
five years and only one in two frontline
workers are benefiting from the
technology advances that information
workers have seen so the disengagement
that comes because frontline workers
aren't getting enough investment aren't
getting the right technology it has a
high price for companies and for the
economy as a whole according to a
McKinsey study frontline workers are
more pessimistic than their managers
about leadership and motivation and
we've also seen just as a standard that
store employees turnover was 65% much
higher than the industry average that
turnover coupled with potentially lost
revenue because frontline worker isn't
as informed about something that they
need to be that all can create
disengaged employees that cost the US
economy between four hundred and eighty
three
to 605 billion in lost productivity
every year so it's a real problem so
we've talked about the outsized impact
that frontline workers have and we've
talked about the fact that they might
not be getting enough investment so it's
clear to us at Google that digitally
empowered frontline workers aren't a
luxury but there are necessity in
today's fast paced moving digital
economy and we think that cloud can
unlock the potential of this workforce
on one hand it creates a better employee
experience by giving employees more
information that they need to do their
job by ensuring that they're engaged and
connected with the organization and
those happy employees are then able to
provide better customer service and
experience along with that cloud
technology can be used for things like
personalization or better processes that
make it smoother for the customer to
interact with your brand
it's like self-service for instance and
cloud has stronger security and
increased value Chrome Enterprise the OS
devices and browser is the right choice
for your organization when thinking
about how to put the power of the cloud
in the hands of your frontline workers
it has benefits for both workers and for
your business for frontline workers it
can increase access to information you
can put applications through the Google
Play Store into the hands of your
frontline workers they can access
applications via the web browser and if
you use VDI for both desktop and app
virtualization that works with chrome
devices as well
chrome devices are fast and familiar one
of the things that we hear a lot when
talking to our customers is that
frontline workers might not be as
digitally savvy as an information worker
and so they need something that's really
easy to on board for employees also
their onboarding a lot of employees at a
time so they need something again
that's easy to use Chrome OS is built on
a browser foundation and people know how
to use a browser so it's just quick and
instant for them to use and there's a
versatility of devices for any use case
that you need them for for your business
Chrome enterprise is secure by design
and I'll talk more about that in a bit
it's also easy to share and manage and
the big benefit here is frontline
workers are in a bunch of different
locations spread out not always at
headquarters and able to interact with
IT and so when IT can remotely manage
they can scale and we've heard from a
lot of our customers that they can go
from you know 200 to 600 employees over
time while maintaining the same set of
IT resources because of that easy to
manage and Chrome Enterprise is a smart
investment so let's talk about the
benefits to the frontline workers first
first of all it helps them get their
valuable time back now we've all been
there where we're waiting for our device
to boot or waiting for an update to
happen and that's lost productivity time
Chromebooks boot in six seconds or less
I just open up my laptop and I can get
to work right away this is one of for me
personally the best things about
Chromebooks and updates happen in the
background so I don't have to sit there
waiting for 30 minutes waiting for that
progress bar to go around for my update
to start for me to get back to work it
just happens seamlessly I don't even
know what's happening but I know my
device is secure and cloud-based
profiles enable a consistent experience
across any device so I can be a mobile
worker walking the hospital floor and I
can log in to any device that's near me
with my cloud profile and I get the
experience that I need or if I've lost
my device or my device is broken I just
pick up another curl book sign in and
I'm ready to get working and with on
device AI and m/l I can also find my
applications much faster that way I have
the information in front of me that I
need to do my job
and chrome devices have a wide variety
of form factors and come from all the
major OEMs
so there's tablets for a store associate
who's roaming the floors and helping out
customers
there's clam shells and convertible
devices for employees who need a device
in a stationary location or mobile
workers and there's of course desktops
for those employees who are at a desk
all day like a call center employee and
all chrome devices come with a standard
10 plus hours of battery life which
means I can be working all day long
without having to charge my device and
we have form factors that are more
rugged and tough for those environments
that need a solution like that so let's
talk about the security of Chrome
Enterprise this is an area that our
engineering teams spend a lot of time
focused on from the firmware all the way
through the applications Chromebooks
Chrome OS and Chrome browser are secured
by design with multiple layers of
security this way
employees don't feel fault to harmful
attacks like malware attacks and if one
does prevail it prevents that from
spreading across the OS with things like
sandboxing and side isolation and with
verified boot i'm ensured that tampered
OS never boots up on my operating system
and if you didn't know there are
actually two operating systems on a
chrome device so when I boot up my sheet
in my machine if one has been tampered
with
it'll seamlessly boot up the other OS in
the background and this is great because
we hear a lot from IT departments that
they want to make sure frontline workers
have a really secure device because
first of all their hourly employees
there is turnover but also frontline
workers are working with a lot of
customer and patient data and it's
really important that that data remain
secure and that these employees don't
fall for harmful attacks like fishing
or malware and then of course there's
regular and controlled updates that
happen in the background every six weeks
you can push an update to your employees
you don't have to worry about them
accepting the update or not it just
happens seamlessly in the background and
with the Chrome Enterprise license you
can manage your entire fleet of devices
there's 200 plus user and device
policies so you can make sure that your
employees only have access to the
applications that they need that it's
preloaded with the information that you
wanted to have you could even do things
like lock down the on device drive so
that employees can't save any
information to the actual device and
it's secure in the cloud and the Chrome
Enterprise license allows you to work
with your current infrastructure so
integrating with things like your
enterprise mobility management solution
or the identity that you choose to have
and of course it comes with 24/7 support
now one of the areas in IT management
that Google and our customers have seen
lots of benefits for are in significant
deployment and support savings so Google
has a mixed ecosystem we use Windows
devices Mac OS and of course Chrome OS
and what our internal teams have seen is
that a Chrome OS device takes thirty
three minutes to deploy compared to two
hours and 21 minutes with a Windows
Device think about all the devices that
you have to deploy over a period of time
that's significant savings for the IT
department and then when we look at
support savings there's only 19 to ckets
for Chrome OS for every 1,000 active
devices compared to 95 for Windows so
less things are going wrong on the
Chrome OS devices that the IT department
has to handle the other really special
thing about Chrome OS is the
unparalleled multi-user experience so
this means a few things one I could
securely share devices between users
through encrypted crowd cloud
files if I'm using ephemeral mode as
soon as an employee signs the attitude
advice the device is wiped and it's been
ready for the next employee to sign into
and this is really important when you
think about the fact that a frontline
workers could be sharing one device up
to ten employees using that device and
you don't have to worry about anything
being left on the device when the next
person signs them it also means that I
can flexibly configure my devices for
whatever use case that I need in an
instance
so I could take this Chromebook today
and use it for customer self-service and
manage guests mode and I could deploy it
in a few hours to an information worker
who needs to use it for their regular
business and I can sign into any
Chromebook to pick up where I've left
off so I talked about this before but if
my device were to break I could just
pick up another Chromebook sign in use
it instantly and be productive now all
of this the productivity from the
end-user the decreased IT resources
needed as well as the hardware and
software cost avoidance that adds up to
big benefits for the business we
conducted a total economic impact study
with Forrester and according to the
composite organization using shared
Chromebook devices they realized over
three years 1.5 million in hardware and
software cost avoidance 3.5 million in
employee productivity gains and a 75%
improvement in IT productivity now
depending on your use case you might
also want to add on a productivity suite
and Chromebook works with anything that
you need it to but we recommend of
course G suite to help with
collaboration and communication using
drive and Docs sheets and slides you can
share information to your employees and
they can easily consume it in the cloud
and they can also share information back
and it's really important to have that
two-way communication between frontline
workers and HQ because again they have
that wealth of information and knowledge
about what's going on
and then with things like Gmail hangouts
and the new product currents you can
also make sure that you're having that
two-way communication and keeping
employees engaged and with the Google
admin council you can manage both
Chromebooks and G suite from the same
place Angi suite is built with powerful
Google search and AI so it's faster to
get things done the solution that brings
this all together one of the new
solutions that we introduced a few
months ago with our partners its grab
and go with chrome enterprise now we
develop this here at Google as a loaner
program so if my device breaks down I go
to a shelf staffed with Chromebooks I
pick up a Chromebook I sign in I use it
for the day no interaction with IT
needed and then when I'm done with it I
simply mark that I'm returning it sign
out put it back on the shelf and then
it's ready for the next person to pick
up again
no IT involvement needed this means that
I have 24 access to that and that it
saves IT a bunch of time and expense so
this is used for a loaner program but
you can imagine using it for a shift
worker a call center employee comes in
they pick up the device they need when
they're done the next shift starts and
they can pick up those same devices that
helps you have less devices on hand and
also saves IT money and and time and
getting those shift workers the devices
that they mean so I've talked a lot
about Chrome enterprise and the benefits
that it has for frontline workers now I
want to go through some actual use cases
and customers that we have seen
implement chrome devices to their
frontline workers so let's start with
the first one of digitizing engagement
and training I think we all know how
important training is but it can be
difficult when you have a decentralized
employee base so think about people who
are working in a retail environment for
instance they don't have access to come
into HQ when they need training so you
need to be able to deploy training to
these employees and a lot of employees
don't have one too
devices to just be able to do that
training on their own time so you can
either have a pool of devices and we see
a lot of customers actually start with
Chromebooks here because it's a isolated
environment that they can put these
devices in without a lot of change
management we also see retail and food
service companies have these devices in
the back office
which then allows employees to go to the
back of the office when they have a
chance get their training fill out their
HR paperwork do other things along those
lines on those back office devices and
one of those customers is Panda Express
Panda Express recently adopted
Chromebooks in its back office so that
its employees could get training to make
your favorites like orange chicken and
kung pao chicken
so that they have a consistent
experience across every single one of
their locations and these employees can
use it for training they can also use
the same device to log into their office
365 environment if they need to do more
productivity oriented tasks and they
worked with their partner their channel
partner to create a application that
allows employees to use these training
modules offline because some of the
locations have Wi-Fi that isn't as
consistent as others another area that
we've seen a lot of adoption is
improving back-of-house processes
so think about manufacturers on on the
line who need the latest product specs
or people who are in a warehouse who are
shipping and need that information about
what they need to be shipping really
instantly and seamlessly a lot of this
is actually today being done on
paper-based processes and that's just
simply insecure and it also causes
things to be out of date I mean there's
only so many times you can update a
paper before you give it to a shift
worker and things can even change during
a shift so one of our customers of San
Nina they're a global manufacturing and
supply chain company they manufacture a
variety of products including intensive
care unit monitors it's really important
for them
have version control for these types of
ICU monitors because they're critical
right so they moved all 75 of their
factories from a paper-based
manufacturing to chrome devices and now
I'm going to show you a video of how San
Nina has done this sent Mina is a
world-class global manufacturing and
supply chain help me you may never have
heard of us but the products we build
are extremely high reliability whether
it's a warfighter or it's someone in ICU
in the hospital people's lives depend on
if something happens we need to be able
to understand how that product was built
20 years ago you had a lot of
information but none of it was useful it
was sorting through file cabinets and
folders and paper one of the biggest
transformations for us on our
manufacturing floor was going from
paper-based manufacturing process
instructions to a cloud-based system the
importance of document control is huge
when you build high reliability product
today we have everything stored safely
and smartly in the cloud so chrome is a
cloud first operating system that powers
our operations a chrome based system is
much better than where we were
previously the hardware's cheaper and
also the cost of data security is a
piece that you can't even quantify with
insane meaning that we've got 75
factories it's hard to walk around the
factory in Thailand and a factory in
Ireland in the same day with Chrome OS
and 42 cubed being closely integrated
throughout our factories we're able to
do real-time data analytics anywhere in
the world they really are the backbone
of everything we do it's a Mena and
Chrome OS is the operating system with
that runs one so chrome is empowering
everyone to be a cloud worker
with the help of Chrome OS were a lot
more efficient and a lot more secure
than we were before when you see the
products we build that really do change
people's lives it makes it emotional and
personal so let's talk about customer
contact centers these are highly
important to having great customer
service if you think about when your
most recently called up a contact center
you're probably frustrated about some
things that's what led you to call them
but someone who's on the other line and
that's really knowledgeable that gets
you your information straight away that
could probably change the way that you
think about that incident and help save
the day for that brand so it's important
that contact centers have technology
that's really easy to use that is simple
and that's fast and we've seen a lot of
companies adopt Chrome Enterprise for
their contact centers for these reasons
one of our customers MercadoLibre
their company that operates online
marketplaces they were struggling with
the Windows machines that they were
using because of the long boot times and
in fact sometimes it would take up to
five minutes to boot a device and in an
hourly shift environment five minutes is
just five minutes too long so
MercadoLibre with the help of our
partner never we're updated their
existing hardware with Chrome OS and now
with the six second boot time they're
able to save two hundred and fifty
minutes per shift across all of their
employees it's a lot of time saved it
also helps the employees start their day
off better perhaps be happier in
addition to that because of the cloud
native nature of the operating system
MercadoLibre can have their associates
work from anywhere so in case of a
disaster or in case they lose power at
their contact center headquarters these
associates are able to work from home
using Chrome operating system because
they can just sign in and get their
entire profile there for them
every device that they have whatever
chrome devices they have on hand the
next area that I would talk about is
front of house workers so these are the
workers that are in front of your
employee or in front of your customers
they're the ones helping out you know
picking a dress for a special occasion
or helping them sign up for a bank
account in this instance and friend line
in front of house workers they need
technology at their fingertips right
away to be able to help customers we did
a survey with Forrester that found one
of the top pain points for frontline
workers with technology is that they
have to leave their customers in the
middle of an interaction to go find
information just makes for a bad
experience for everyone
so you can put technology into the hands
of your front of house workers give them
laptops or tablets on the floor but you
could also help them out by offloading
some of that work on to customers with
customer self-service and in fact a lot
of customers like serving themselves
before they need to talk to an associate
charles schwab did this when they were
introducing their new swab intelligent
portfolios they wanted to introduce a
customer self-service solution into
their branches that was easy to use for
someone of any technical ability that
was easy to manage because they have
lots of different branches and they
didn't want their associates to have to
troubleshoot and so they introduced
Chrome devices as this solution now when
someone walks into a branch and wants to
learn more about these portfolios an
associate can hand them a Chromebook
they can explore the offerings and then
they could do the application straight
from there this helps cut down this time
for the associate and it also has helped
to eliminate some common errors that
might happen if you're doing two-way
communication to fill out an application
the last one that I want to talk to you
about today is information all the go
now think about field workers or mobile
workers who need to be able to tap into
a device wherever they are they need a
reliable device they need a device that
can
give them the information they need very
quickly and nowhere else is this more
apparent than for EMTs and Middlesex
Hospital one of our customers they were
having trouble with the devices that
they were using for their EMTs they were
breaking down a lot they weren't
available in those crucial seconds that
EMTs need to get information and so they
adopted chrome devices and now I'm gonna
show you a video about how Middlesex has
helped their EMT workers with chrome
devices we respond to approximately
10,000 911 calls a year
instead of having to wait until the call
is complete we can get started
immediately with a Chromebook
the technology for us has to be patient
centric to operate in the Chrome
environment with no learning curve has
been a huge advantage for us healthcare
IT is undergoing a bit of a shift for
the last 15 20 years no longer do you
have a $3,000 PC that was for a specific
use case our on-call doctors our EMS
they are roaming workers the ability to
easily handoff one device to multiple
people without leaving a footprint of
what they were working on or where
they've been it allows a great deal of
flexibility what we're doing is bringing
the emergency department to the patient
so our technology is critical we've had
zero failures with the Chromebooks when
they open they're on and they're ready
to go they definitely give us a better
level of confidence when we're out in
the field Google Cloud and Chrome
provides us an opportunity to bring a
modern secure platform into the
healthcare arena and the chrome
integration with Citrix allows us to
access our legacy applications
what Google is allowing us to do is put
the focus back on our patients so if you
like what you heard today and want to
learn more about how chrome enterprise
can help your frontline workers and hear
about more case studies please visit our
website at geo chrome slash frontline
workers we have a white paper there that
you can read more about and you can also
get in touch with us for more
information so please stay tuned for
live Q&A we'll be back in less than a
minute
you
okay and we're back with frequently
asked questions so the first one can we
invest in chrome hardware while still
maintaining our office 365 environment
the answer is yes you can and I gave the
example about Panda Express that's using
office 365 with their chrome devices for
their front line workers the thing that
I would recommend is figure out how your
employees are using office 365 they can
access the Android application and they
can access the web version if that's
enough and it should be enough for
almost all front line workers especially
and then it should be as easy as just
letting them access via the Android app
or the web app no special updates needed
there so yes you can use office 365 on a
Chromebook the second question is there
any way to restrict access so that
employees only has access to certain
applications yes you can so there are a
few things to talk about here one is
manage Google Play Store so you can
whitelist and blacklist applications so
that employees only have access to
certain applications in Google Play and
then you can also black list so that
they can't download but often what our
customers are doing is going even
further than that and you could very
easily administer policies that lock a
device down to just a few applications
and we see this happening a lot so if
you for instance are in a warehouse we
have a customer stitch fix who does this
they have certain applications that
employees on the warehouse use for their
day-to-day work and then they also have
applications to things like timesheets
or any of the HR administration that
they need to do as well what are our
options to have users sign in without an
identity for temporary access well I'm
glad you asked we have managed guest
session and this allows people to sign
in without using identity while still
giving you full access to manage the
device the applications of the browser
so we have
our customers who are doing a lot of
self-service with their own customers
using managed to get session and you
could also use it in those sorts of
environments where maybe you have one
device that's there for people to do
more administration tasks where they
don't need to use an identity you can
just set the device up with manage get
session through the Google admin console
how do customers currently deal with
offline capabilities or limited Wi-Fi
situations so we'll first start with one
thing which is to miss the bus the fact
that Chromebooks don't work offline
Chromebooks do work offline I use mine
often while I'm traveling on airplanes
when I don't have access to great Wi-Fi
you can use G suite Gmail offline and
there's also certain applications that
work offline some of our customers do a
couple things what they're our krob
devices that are enabled with LTE so
that is an option you could use a Wi-Fi
hotspot so that's something that
Middlesex Hospital does for their EMTs
and then the customer example that I
gave with Panda Express they're using
one of their partners to create an
application for their training that
works offline in this way they don't
have the dependency on Wi-Fi and then
the last question Mac OS and windows
already provide regular updates so
what's the difference with Chrome OS so
Chrome OS not only provides regular
updates but one it does it in the
background this way you don't have to
worry about your employees accepting
those updates they just happen so you
don't have that delay you don't have to
worry about the fact that someone who's
just been delinquent on updating their
device and they also happen every six
weeks consistently you can choose
whether or not you want to implement
those every six weeks but if you do that
helps to mitigate any issues a lot
quicker so that's all the questions that
we have thank you for tuning in please
visit cloud on air to discover more
content from google cloud experts thanks
you
[Music]
you